[Music]
as we look out across the universe we
see nebulas
stars
and planets all constructed from visible
matter but what we see is just a small
part of the cosmos the rest is invisible
unknown the dark universe
dark universe is a very common phrase to
describe our universe because it turns
out most of our cosmos is dark dark
Nonna's and night dark as in doesn't
interact with light and dark as in we
don't really understand it all the
objects in our daily experience our
bodies the air the chair that you're
sitting in the planets and stars all of
that only adds up to 5% of the universe
it's the other 95% that is the dark
stuff the dark universe the dark
universe is made of two forces dark
matter and dark energy in a way the dark
matter and dark energy sort of oppose
each other dark matter has positive
gravity it pulls things together and
dark energy has repulsive gravity that
pushes things apart
to encapsulate of that in one sentence
dark matter is attractive dark energy is
repulsive
since the dawn of time two forces
slugging it out for control of the
universe dark matter and dark energy are
locked in this epic struggle the dark
matters trying to bring things together
the dark energy is trying to drive
everything apart so it's basically a
battle who's gonna win
it's a struggle that started 13.8
billion years ago in the cosmic furnace
of the Big Bang the infant universe was
a super hot ball of intense radiation
but suddenly it started to transform it
cooled and expanded triggering the birth
of the regular universe and the dark
universe scientists believe that both
dark matter and dark energy formed in
the first moments of the Big Bang
it would have formed probably just
fractions of a second after the Big Bang
around the time that normal matter
formed and the processes that created
the normal matter we know all about
similar processes probably created the
dark matter
during these first microseconds the
universe was a hot dense ball of matter
and energy there are two sides of the
same coin matter can convert into energy
and energy can convert directly into
matter visible particles of regular
matter forming atoms planets stars and
us and other particles they are
invisible they are dark matter the big
mysteries that we as astronomers have to
solve is what this dark matter is we
just don't know the idea of a type of
matter that you can't see and that acts
differently than normal matter is sort
of out there it's sort of weird
but the dark universe does leave clues
it's like a crime scene you know that a
crime has been committed even though you
don't know the perpetrator yet we see
the hints we see the signs we see the
signals that something funny is
happening in our universe even though we
don't know exactly what's causing it
there are several contenders for what
dark matter could be it could be normal
matter that we just don't see or it
could be some sort of exotic matter a
particle of some sort that we haven't
detected yet it could be a species of
particle like an electron like a proton
like a quark but a special kind that
doesn't interact with light one of the
favorite possible models of dark matter
are wimps weakly interacting massive
particles wimps may not interact
strongly with other matter for light but
they do exert a gravitational pull
so they're the best candidates for the
particles of dark matter that formed in
the Big Bang the early universe was
intensely hot and dense full of new
particles of both visible matter and
invisible dark matter but another force
is present dark energy
dark energy has existed since the time
of the Big Bang dark energy was always
there we don't know how much of it there
was but it's possible that the same
amount of dark energy was always there
our understanding of what that dark
energy is is very limited if you were to
ask a roomful of 10 theoretical
physicists on the nature of dark energy
you'd get about 12 different answers
we're not sure what dark energy is dark
energy is just a fancy name for our
ignorance dark energy is nothing more
than a placeholder name for this
enormous gap in our understanding of how
the cosmos works but we don't understand
it at all that's true one potential
answer to what dark energy actually is
may be found in so-called empty space
could this be the source of dark energy
we use the think of space it's just
boring emptiness but now I think it's
healthier to think of space this is kind
of substance a substance that carries a
strange type of energy every small
region of space has a little bit of
energy in it just associated with the
vacuum itself vacuum energy is the idea
that vacuum isn't empty that there's
something there there's an energy in it
with a kind of anti-gravity
perhaps this vacuum energy that pushes
against gravity is the mysterious dark
energy we simply don't know we're not
sure that the dark energy is the vacuum
energy it could be a new type of energy
that permeates all of space thus is what
we're trying to measure now dark energy
and dark matter forged in the intense
heat of the Big Bang opposing forces one
attractive one repulsive but together
over 13.8 billion years they will shape
the history of the universe
you